[Music]
a jammed republican gubernatorial
primary a close gop race for senate
today really a very busy primary
election day we thank you for staying
with us i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez today's results will determine
who is going to appear on the general
election ballot that's in november polls
opened at seven o'clock this morning and
they close at seven o'clock tonight so
far more than 33 thousand votes have
been cast in clark county that is for
votes cast at polling places we don't
have mail ballot totals just yet it's
still pretty darn early yes it is and if
you miss the chance to vote early you
can still vote in person or you can drop
off your mail-in ballot at a polling
station today that's a quicker way to do
it all ballots that are mailed must be
postmarked by today or earlier to be
counted ballots received through june
18th will be counted after that not
counted
so halfway through election day and
voters are still making their ways to
the polls rancho high school really
popular polling location in past years
that's where victoria saha joins us live
to tell us what the turnout has been
there hi victoria
hey guys a little different this year
here at rancho high school in the
northeast valley i'm told that it's been
slow about 50 people have come in to
vote throughout the day since they
opened at 7 a.m but people working here
say they expect there to be an uptick of
voters coming in once they get off of
work for nevada's primary there are
numerous races residents of nevada
wanted to have their input on who will
square off with governor steve
sissellach and locally voting for who
gets to sit on the clark county school
board i spoke to voter jacqueline
bodusana she's been voting for 47 years
and has never missed an election
i truly believe that it's our gift
that our forefathers give to us
and i believe in
voting
if i don't vote
who is going to be my voice
she says with recent events such as the
war in ukraine and discussion of
abortion rights and seeing so many
homeless in her area she wants to make
sure she has a voice in who has a seat
in office this location will be open
until 7 pm you can also drop in your
mail-in ballots here as well reporting
from rancho high school victoria saha
live local now
victoria thank you stay tuned to 8 news
now for complete coverage of today's
primary we'll be keeping you updated all
night you can find the latest including
results as we get them online at
eightnewsnow.com
and if you still have not voted we do
have a special election guide at
eightnewsnow.com we have details where
to vote in person and information on
some of those candidates remember you
have until seven o'clock tonight